T'inquiète pas villageoise.
Je vais pas te faire de mal.
Je voulais juste provoquer l'autre clochard de Belyr.
Ah d'accord. Ok, ok.
Attends, c'est beaucoup plus clair là pour moi.
Parce que depuis tout à l'heure, je me dis "le mec est fou".
"Il arrive de nul part, il me kidnappe genre c'est normal."
Eh, eh ! C'est normal.
Je suis le seigneur.
Je te kidnappe si je veux.
J'ai le droit de cuissage, c'est la loi, je suis le seigneur.
Ok... D'accord.
Ouais.
Bah allons-y.
Allons-y quoi ?
Bah allons-y là, faire tout ce que... avec moi là...
Mais non, je ne veux pas.
Et bah on fait pas !
Non, on fait pas.
Mais si je voulais, on ferait.
Ok, attends... Excuse-moi, ça va trop vite entre nous...
Je suis désolée. C'est pas toi, c'est moi...
Mais ça me fait des trucs que j'avais pas envie de revivre...
J'ai l'impression qu'on s'engueule comme si on était un couple.
Alors qu'on est pas du tout un couple, tu vois ?
Et moi, je m'étais promis de jamais plus revivre ça.
Le mieux c'est que je prenne mes distances, d'accord  ?
Donc ça n'a rien à voir avec toi.
Excuse-moi.
Bien tenté.
Mais je suis désolé.
Il m'a dit "déchire un truc", j'ai pas réfléchi.
Mais fallait que je le fasse parce que sinon Aelys allait griller que j'étais en train de t'aider.
Mais c'est rien ça, c'est rien.
Comparé à ce qu'est en train d'arriver à cette pauvre Geneviève là.
Elle doit être terrifiée.
Merci.
Et puis même, il faut arrêter Aelys, il devient complètement fou !
Bon, heureusement, je connais un passage secret...
Qui nous mènerait directement à la salle du trône.
Un passage que seul moi, et quelques livreurs de bouffe on connait.
Le souci, c'est qu'ils connaissent ma face.
Tu vas avoir besoin d'un costume.
Très bien, tu as le costume.
Maintenant, il faut que tu rentres dans la peau du personnage.
Elle est immonde ta phrase.
Il faut que tu sois quelqu'un que tu n'es pas.
Ok.
Euh bonjour, je suis un gros lâche de moine.
Qui fait des potions.
Oh non, j'ai mis ça dans une chaussure.
C'est moi ça ?
Exact, tu t'es reconnu.
Oui mais c'était très spécifique.
Non mais il faut pas que tu m'imites moi.
Il faut que tu inventes un personnage qui n'existe pas.
Comme un paysan.
Un céréalier !
Dis donc, si vous voulez des céréales, va falloir me demander à l'avance, hein.
Parce que y a beaucoup de demande.
C'est très mauvais.
C'est très très mauvais.
Je pense que le mieux, c'est que tu parles pas du tout.
T'es nouveau toi ?
Oui.
T'es vraiment nul en complot.
Et toi, t'es vraiment si pressé que ça de me tuer ?
Tu veux vraiment le faire là, maintenant, sur la table ?
Ça sonnait sexuel hein, mais c'était pas sexuel, hein.
Oui bon, une dernière volonté ?
Oui.
Tranche-toi la gorge avec un tesson de bouteille.
Refusé ! Adieu Belyr.
Attends !
Quoi ?
Je te défi.
En duel judiciaire.
Oh mais arrête avec ça !
Je t'ai dit, j'ai changé maintenant.
Les duels ça se passent avec des bûchers.
On allume deux bûchers et celui qui brûle pas, il gagne.
J'accepte.
Attends, quoi ?
T'as très bien entendu.
C'est vrai ?
Oh ça me fait tellement plaisir !
Tu vas cramer mais ça me fait hyper plaisir !
Je pensais que jamais personne accepterait ça !
Je te demande juste une chose Aelys.
Ouais ?
Je veux pouvoir me préparer dans ma chaumière.
Mais y a pas de soucis !
Je te colle 2 soldats au cul, je garde la villageoise en otage...
Et si jamais t'essaye de fuir, je la bute.
Ça va ?
Ça va, bon deal de fils de pute.
Avec plaisir.
Je peux te prendre un peu de poulet ?
Bute-le.
Ok bon j'y vais.
Mais enfin, pourquoi tu as demandé ça ?
Mais je sais pas moi, il allait me couper la tête !
J'étais prêt à faire n'importe quoi pour sauver ma peau !
Alors toi pour sauver ta peau, tu demandes un duel au bûcher !
C'est le premier truc qui m'est venu à l'esprit !
Puis je sais qu'il adore les bûchers.
Est-ce que t'as conscience qu'il va te jeter dans les flammes ?
Oui, oui, justement.
Je me disais, qu'avec ta science, tu arriverais peut-être à faire des flammes qui brûlent pas.
Oh oui bah non, le feu c'est le feu.
Je peux pas.
Non mais une fois t'avais réussi à faire de la pluie qui faisait des guilis !
Mais c'était de la loc !
Oh putain.
Mais y a bien une solution ?
Ben ouais mais je... mais je vois pas.
Ah si !
Si !
Je peux te faire une potion d'invulnérabilité.
Mais attention, c'est temporaire.
C'est à base d'une plante très rare qui s'appelle le scrilax...
Yorel peu importe ! Peu importe.
J'ai plus que toi, d'accord ?
Si t'arrives à faire cette potion et que ça marche...
On arrivera à prouver à tout le monde qu'Aelys est un gros connard.
Et qu'il est sur le trône pour de mauvaises raisons.
Comme ça je récupèrerai mon pouvoir.
Je sauverai le Royaume.
Je prendrai Geneviève, je vais la dé... je sauverai le Royaume.
Ça se tente.
Yorel !
Oui ?
Tu peux le faire.
Je suis dans la merde.